alors le 2 Jacob dernier une femme de 66
ans Muguette et seul à son domicile son
mari n'est pas encore rentré il est 20h
elle est en train de rebrancher une
télévision dans sa chambre et d'un seul
coup elle voit une ombre
furtive dans son salon donc elle réagit
instantanément elle interpelle le
l'ombre en lui demandant mais qu'est-ce
que vous faites chez moi et l'individu
porte une capuche un sac à dos et quitte
assez précipitamment le domicile la
Huguette hurle donne l'alerte appel son
mari lequel Marie appelle la belle-sœur
la belle-sœur appelle les gendarmes
enfin bon il y a tout un enchaînement de
d'appel l'alerte est donnée et les cris
de de cette femme un voisin qui était à
l'extérieur à ce moment-là lui mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle raconte
rapidement cette ce qui s'est passé
et ce voisin va se lancer à la poursuite
du voleur
rejoint par d'autres ils sont en tout
une vingtaine il y a des chiens et ils
finissent par voir un type qui
correspond au signalement donné par
Muguette il lui saute dessus ils vont le
rouer de coule et chiens vont s'en mêler
les chiens vont mordre
ils vont le pulvériser
et les un des individus des
protagonistes va appeler les gendarmes
mais il est déjà tard il est 21h40 5 je
crois et lorsque les gendarmes arrivent
sur place ils ne peuvent que constater
l'état critique de ce garçon ce garçon
il s'appelle Jérémy Jérémy Da Silva il a
39 ans
et honnêtement en l'état rien ne prouve
c'est oui que c'est lui on le retrouve
pas parce que le préjudice c'est une
carte bleue et 45 euros on ne retrouve
pas sur lui ni la carte bleue ni de
l'argent liquide
on sait que dans l'après-midi il était
avec sa petite amie qui s'appelle Olivia
à Nice ils ont passé un moment ensemble
et puis son un peu embrouillés ce qui
fait que elle va remonter à l'Escarène
en voiture pendant que Jérémy donc la
victime va prendre le train et là où on
peut peut-être trouver une explication
c'est qu'à la gare de l'Escarène pour
aller à son domicile il y a environ 800
mètres Jérémy va passer devant le
domicile de Muguette
et peut-être qu'il y a eu une confusion
je dis pas que Muguette a eu des
hallucinations mais en l'état d'ailleurs
ça fait quand même deux mois que cette
histoire
a eu lieu c'était le 12 octobre
l'enquête n'a pas avancé d'un millimètre
personne n'a été mise en examen et entre
temps j'ai oublié évidemment de dire le
principal c'est que Jérémy est décédé
des suites de ses blessures d'une
perforation de l'intestin grêle suite à
des coûts donc vous imaginez la violence
une vingtaine à priori mais c'est une
horde sauvage c'est une horde sauvage ce
qui est très étonnant c'est qu'entre le
12 octobre et aujourd'hui avant
l'enquête de Nice-Matin il y a une
chatte de plomb il y a eu l'omerta total
dans ce village de 2500 habitants comme
si effectivement personne ne voulait
parler et ça c'est très étonnant et même
les enquêteurs ne comprennent pas c'est
vrai que pour le moment les les
enquêteurs ils sont face à un mur ils
n'arrivent pas à faire parler les gens
donc l'enquête est très compliqué c'est
incroyable cette tomata c'est très rare
en France si vous voulez c'est pas si
étonnant que ça parce que de il y a 2500
habitants dans ce dans ce petit village
et parmi la vingtaine d'agresseurs il y
a probablement le fils de je ne sais
trop combien de famille et bien
évidemment ils ont pas du tout envie de
parler donc oui effectivement vous avez
raison il y a l'omerta mais voilà la
raison je crois que c'est celle-là alors
dites-moi il paraît justement qu'il y a
un des criminels qui aurait été
identifié vous allez me dire si c'est
vrai ou pas et qui est en fuite à
l'étranger c'est ce que oui
effectivement ça confirme oui et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a une hype en ce moment
de se faire la justice soi-même et on
voit là que c'est typiquement une bombe
à retardement parce que les milices
armées les chasses à l'homme les
règlements de comptes comme ça c'est une
catastrophe donc la justice il faut que
la justice passe il faut que la justice
soit pas laxiste et la justice c'est pas
ça en fait voilà évidemment c'est une
carte bleue il y a peut-être un mec qui
n'est pas responsable qui a été buté
tout à fait ce dossier c'est la
démonstration de la limite de l'exercice
de la entre guillemets de la milice
privée de la police
au gouvernement alors ce que dit la
compagne de Jérémy c'est que il
travaillait en CDI dans une entreprise
qui gagnait 2500 euros par mois voilà et
elle dit c'est vrai c'est vrai que
parfois il avait l'alcool mauvais comme
on dit c'est vrai qu'il a commis
quelques petites infractions mais
pourquoi est-ce que aujourd'hui en
octobre là il aurait volé une carte
bleue et 45 euros alors qu'il avait un
CDI voilà ce que dit sa compagne et
elle-même est originaire du village
je crois qu'il y a des il y avait des
caméras de surveillance dans le village
est-ce qu'elles ont parlé ce qu'on les a
fait parler est-ce qu'elles ont indiqué
des choses parce que ça reste quand même
très flou alors effectivement il y en a
un qui a été identifié probablement par
le système de vidéo surveillance les
enquêteurs sont très discrets sur leur
truc c'est que Jérémy c'est toujours pas
c'est lui ou pas avant on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas l'enquête là-dessus en tout
cas on a pas d'éléments qui qui prouve
que c'est lui et quand bien même ce
serait lui non mais non mais bien sûr
non mais oui mais c'est pour savoir
un des auteurs donc comme elle a dit il
est en fuite à l'étranger un mandat
d'arrêt aurait été délivré à son
encombre et c'est vrai que ce qu'on a
dit c'est vraiment comme vous avez dit
c'est une horde sauvage qui s'est jeté
sur lui une meute
aujourd'hui par la gendarmerie de Nice
la SR de Nice c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les habitants indiquent que les
journalistes ne devraient pas s'occuper
de cette affaire encore ne pas vouloir
s'emmêler et répondre aux questions
c'est privé ça ne regarde pas je ne veux
pas ils disent qu'ils ne veulent pas
d'histoire c'est tellement facile ah oui
c'est fou de dire c'est totalement
facile c'est fou de dire ça il y a quand
même
culpabilité doit ressentir le village
parce qu'ils se connaissent tous c'est à
2500 habitants tout le monde doit se
connaître et tout le monde doit supposer
qui a fait quoi et même ils doivent
savoir donc ils veulent ils se protègent
bien sûr il se protège tous mais c'est
affreux alors ça c'est l'autodéfense des
citoyens horribles on peut comprendre il
y a eu laxisme des tribunaux aussi
justifie rien la violence et l'horreur
qui s'est passé
et c'est vrai que ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que sa compagne dit que à
l'hôpital à la réussite à le faire
parler qu'il a ni avoir volé qu'on a
retrouvé aucune affaire donc c'est vrai
qu'un immense doute sur sa culpabilité
pour le moment et par rapport au village
il y a des gens qui semblent-ils ont
essayé d'arrêter cette horde
c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a qui disent
maintenant j'ai essayé mais je n'ai rien
pu faire ils étaient déchaînés
effectivement ils ont lâché les chiens
alors
clim raciste c'est-à-dire pour justifier
pour justifier les faits Olivia c'est sa
compagne on accompagne Jérémy elle dit
mais c'est il a rien volé il a
effectivement un travail de déménageurs
il a un CDI
ce qui s'est passé c'est un crime
raciste parce qu'on le prenait pour un
arabe dans le village alors qu'il est a
priori d'origine portugais je crois
et qu'il avait peut-être un peu le le
look entre guillemets d'un Arabe et
c'est ce que j'entends
Michel qui nous a retourné bien sûr et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est incroyable et
ça fait suite aussi à tous les
événements qui sont passés avant non
c'est ça c'est quoi c'est tous les
événements qui a eu des ces derniers
temps qui font que les gens ont pété un
câble
je sais pas j'ai du mal à me repérer
dans cette
ultra violence quotidienne
que ce soit toutes les affaires qu'on a
évoqué ici avec vous sur ce plateau
d'autres encore
je ne m'y retrouve pas je constate je
chronique avec
avec difficulté ce type d'affaires me
trouble particulièrement
c'est bien et alors je sais pas d'où ça
vient je sais pas si c'est parce que les
gens sont deviennent fous
je suis pas sociologue mais c'est très
troublant de voir cette montée en
puissance de la de la violence et
peut-être que cette affaire si elle peut
au moins servir à ça
permettra qu'on mette un coup d'arrêt à
se
ses actions de
rendez-vous donc la justice sévisse il
faut que les enquêteurs fassent leur
boulot et que la justice sévise dans ces
cas-là quoi qu'il arrive auprès de là
dans cette affaire mais aussi quand il y
a des victimes et que les coupables ne
sont pas assez chattiers donc c'est sûr
que ça c'est pour ça qu'on a essayé
non mais ce qui était effrayant c'est
que même les pompiers ont été appelés
qu'une heure 15 plus tard ça c'est quand
même une volonté quand même de faire du
mal